...
-Je donne toutes
les Cadillacs civiles,
tous les dîners chez Maxim's,
tous les cinq étoiles de la ville,
avec terrasse et piscine.
Je donne ma Rolex, mon smoking
et mes paires de boots en lézard.
Un mystère 20 et deux Boeings,
tout l'or, tout l'argent,
tout l'ivoire.
Pour une biguine avec toi,
envie d'une biguine avec toi.
Je donne toutes les îles désertes
et tous les palmiers sur la côte.
Et la combinaison secrète
pour ouvrir du coffre la porte.
Je donne les villas bord de mer
et toutes les toiles de Picasso.
Je donne à tord
et à travers mon temps,
ma vie et mon cerveau.
Pour une biguine avec toi,
envie d'une biguine avec toi.
Tududu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tudu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tududu tudu.
Tududu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tudu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tudududu.
Pour une biguine avec toi,
envie d'une biguine avec toi.
Je donne mon paquet de cigarettes,
ma chemise à fleurs,
mon kimono,
mes plans secrets,
mes plantes vertes,
j'offre croisière avec radeau.
Je donne mon lit, ma brosse à dents,
mon esprit tordu mais sincère,
mes tickets de bus et restaurant.
Je donne tout devant moi derrière.
Pour une biguine avec toi,
envie d'une biguine avec toi.
Tududu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tudu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tududu tudu.
Tududu tudu, tududu tudu.
Tudu tudu, tududu tudu.
Pour une biguine avec toi,
envie d'une biguine avec toi.
Pour une biguine avec toi.